even in the nearly three hours of
supernatural horror in Chapter two can't
tie up every loose end left hanging but
never fear because we're here to help
you look back over everything that
happened in the sequel to identify its
most compelling unanswered questions
warning spoilers are ahead Ritchie's
flashback to the arcade strongly implies
he's gay and still in the closet we see
him playing Street Fighter with another
boy and when Ritchie suggests they hang
out more the boy spots his cousin bully
Henry Bowers and goes on the offensive
claiming that Ritchie was hitting on it
when Pennywise appears to Ritchie
shortly afterward he teases him saying
he knows his dirty little secret in 2016
Ritchie takes the death of Eddie harder
than any of the other losers and toward
the end of the film he returns to a
bridge where he carved their initials
together into the rail suggesting that
Ritchie's feelings for Eddie went beyond
friendship we're never told for sure but
it seems likely it's tough not to wonder
exactly how the grown-up losers ever get
in and out of Derry without being
arrested the reunion dinner ends with
them trashing their private dining room
when Pennywise unleashes his illusions
when the hostess walk says she finds
Mike smashing a chair into the table yet
no one so much as scolds them for it
Ritchie screams at a little kid as they
leave the restaurant and bill is there
to watch that same little boy get
devoured by it at the carnival most
egregious Ritchie buries a hatchet in
Bauer's head in the dairy library yet no
police officers show up to so much as
questioned the losers about anything we
never find out how they explain Eddy's
disappearance when Stanley's widows
sends them all a letter he wrote before
killing himself
there aren't any follow-up calls from
curious detectives the only police
you're likely to notice in the film are
the ones beating the hell out of the
young Henry Bowers in a flashback it's
like the cops just disappeared what is
going on the cops it's not just the
police who are missing obviously people
live in Derry but judging by the film
outside of a few scenes at the carnival
it's hard to tell the bed-and-breakfast
where most of the losers are staying is
all but deserted they're constantly
yelling arguing and banging things
around in the entryway Eddy is attacked
in
room by Henry stabs him in the mouth
Eddie stabs Bowers in the chest and the
lunatic retreats out the window no one
ever comes around to ask about the blood
or the broken furniture when bill grabs
the same little boy Ritchie yelled at
earlier in broad daylight and yells at
him that he has to get out of town
there's no one around to ask him what he
thinks he's doing when the losers emerge
from its lair and the house collapses
into the earth there's no one around
then either the streets are even
deserted when they return to downtown
Derry seems like a ghost town and
Stephen King's novel the writer makes it
clear that as threatening as it is the
monster is not the only powerful force
with a stake in what happens in Derry
before their battle with it
the young losers encounter a god-like
space turtle named michurin a benevolent
spiritual force while the direct help
the turtle can offer the heroes is
minimal it does remind them that they
are not alone in their battle but the
turtle exists in little more than Easter
eggs in the it films the young bill
finds a Lego turtle in Georgie's room in
2017 it in the sequel there's a
prominent turtle model in a classroom
those seem to be the only direct nods to
michurin turtle we know it crashed to
earth a long time ago and that its
existence was well known to the Native
Americans who once lived where Derry
Maine is now it's made of dead lights
that's about all we know
in his final battle with the losers
Pennywise refers to himself as the eater
of worlds is it just bragging or is
there more to it than we know this is
another example of more being revealed
in Kings books particularly his Dark
Tower series but even there we don't get
a complete picture not to mention the
fact that there's no reason the it of
the films and the it of the books has to
be the same entity when the losers
reunite we learned that with the
exception of Mike they've mostly
forgotten everything about Derry but
over time we discover at least one of
them maybe hadn't forgotten at all nor
kept their attentions away from the town
entirely Beverly is surprised to learn
about her father's death when mrs.
Kirsch informs her of it but Eddie
remembers all the details of his
mother's passing volunteering the
details of her cancer to the pharmacist
mr. Keane that could mean a couple of
things one that
at the very least kept up with his
mother in Derry until her death giving
him some lingering connection to the
town or two that she also left the town
at some point we don't find out which is
the case though there are some brief
mentions in later King novels including
the Tommyknockers and the Dark Tower
series losers final battle with penny
wise seems to have been the end for the
monster at least as far as its influence
in Derry was concerned a king fan would
likely argue that a return of penny wise
in the movies would be sacrilege but if
it chapter two rakes in the kind of
money it's expected to Hollywood might
be fine with a little sacrilege bitter
because people die right and sweet right
guys making money exactly the questions
it chapter two leaves unanswered could
lay a narrative foundation for the
villains return if it was an alien
couldn't there be more like it and what
if it laid eggs in the book the losers
indeed have to destroy a clutch of eggs
it late could a sequel focus on some
baby it's time and ticket sales will
tell check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]